for me
Socialism or Marxism is not a theory
that I'm reading it was my daily life I
knew how that was actually panned out in
reality now that it's just a nice theory
in a textbook
when I come to America there are so many
people who want that theory they worship
that theory and they hate America
anti-freedom anti-america is so deep
rooted in American left his Minds
literally in the University professor
says the only solution for all these
problems is this mentoring American
System
is showing America destroying Western
Civilization as we know it
and the alternative they wanted is not
even something different but we have
tried the Marxism collectivism socialism
the same ideology that destroyed every
single time it was tried yeah I think
that's why it's so scary how humans are
so dumb keep repeating the same mistake